hi there Steve coffin here today you
know I've been studying Greek enjoying
my Greek tremendously and in fact I'm
about to go down on my stepper and on my
stepper I'm gonna be exercising and
reviewing my Greek vocabulary by the way
I saw an article that said there's some
research done which shows that if you
can study languages while exercising you
are gonna learn faster they have two
groups
you'll learn faster than if you just sit
in the chair so that's by the way but I
will be reading my Greek vocabulary and
of course it's written in Greek letters
and I wanted to focus a bit on Greek
letters because to my mind the joy that
I get from reading Greek letters is a
bit of up of a symbol and example of the
kind of pleasure and sense of
achievement that we get when we learn
languages all my life before I started
learning Greek a few months ago I've
seen Greek letters you know there are
fraternity you know at university you
know Alpha Delta or whatever it might be
or you know the the Alpha and Omega of
something or Epsilon so we're aware of
the fact that there are these Greek
letters and every so often you see a
reference to some Greek term and they'll
write it up in Greek and of course I
could never read it and now I can read
it I can read it and and this is the
same sense of power and achievement that
I had when I could suddenly read Chinese
characters or I could read Russian
novels in the original I saw that and I
think Greek letters like it's it's sort
of in a way quite scintillating Greek
letters preceded Roman letters because
the the Greek alphabet comes from the
Phoenician alphabet and if I'm not
mistaken I'd have to do this you know do
some research but the Roman alphabet
came after the Greek alphabet so we're
going back in time apparently ancient
Greek is different from modern Greek but
it's written with the same letters so I
have this tremendous sense of of
discovery of of going back in time
connecting with something that's that's
quite old now there are other alphabets
that also derived from the Phoenician
alphabet such as for example the Arabic
alphabet and when I study Arabic I will
learn that alphabet I struggled a bit
with Hebrew I'm going back to Hebrew but
I have temporary backed away but it's
sort of the first language where I was
starting to read from right to left
you know the Weger alphabet which is
important in in Asia it's it was the
alphabet of the Mongolians and I believe
of the Manchurians and all of these
alphabets originated with the Phoenician
alphabet but of course the one that I'm
using and enjoying now is the Greek
alphabet one other interesting point on
the grief Greek alphabet it's my
understanding that the that all
alphabets that write from right to left
don't have bowels and of course the
Arabic alphabet the Phoenician alphabet
the Hebrew alphabet they go from right
to left and they have no vowels the
Greeks when they imported the Phoenician
alphabet they also had no vowels and
they went from right to left then they
introduced vowels and they started going
and there's a term which I forget but
which which means as though the ox plows
the field so that the Greek writing used
to go from right to left and then back
to right again and then back to left and
so forth but eventually it converted to
a left to right writing system so it's
very interesting that in world alphabets
those alphabets that have vowels flow
from left to right those alphabets that
don't flow from right to left
why that is I don't know however I'm now
going off to enjoy Greek letters
greeting that letters not as symbols of
fraternities at universities but as
living you know phonetic symbols that
I'm interpreting and I now have very
little trouble reading as I tried
- you know acquire more vocabulary and
become better at Greek which is the the
language that I'm enjoying right now so
I just thought I'd pause a bit and talk
a bit about Greek letters Greek alphabet
the enjoyment I get in reading in other
alphabets and some historical background
that might be of interest to some of you
so thank you for listening and if you
enjoy these podcasts please subscribe
bye for now
[Music]